Devil fruits are the most important power
in one piece, but have you ever thought: “wow,
it would be awesome if we saw THIS POWER in
the story?”
Well, I had the very same idea and asked you
all to submit your wildest, most powerful
devil fruits that would break the one piece
world.
And you won’t believe how hard it was to
sort through almost TWO THOUSAND submissions
to pick out just fifteen of the coolest devil
fruit powers you will ever see.
But let’s first start with just how completely
insane this contest developed.
Because after the VERY FIRST MINUTE that the
contest was open, I already saw three banger
devil fruit ideas, I just knew this was going
to be a MASSIVE CHALLENGE to just pick fifteen.
And I also have to give a HUGE, HUGE thank
you to everyone from all over the world who
submitted your devil fruit.
I just loved to see this amazing community
come together in such an awesome way.
In the end though, after I looked through
every submission, and I mean every single
one, and narrowed the list down to the top
100, plus a separate list of the best funny/meme
submissions which you might see in a future
video.
Then I spent even more time looking through
the top 100, and ended up ranking the top
fifteen fruits based on how completely awesome
they are, but also still made sense as a reasonable
power in the One Piece World.
However, I do have to be honest in that I
did not take any submissions that were actually
already fruits in the story.
And if there were repeat devil fruit submissions
- like the over 100 water fruits, the 42 blood
fruits, and the 37 air/wind fruits - then
I just had to pick the submission with the
best explanation of powers and limitations.
And speaking of limitations, any submission
that was just stupidly broken with absolutely
no restrictions - like the Universe fruit
that lets you do literally anything you want
- I had to throw out as well because there
is no devil fruit in the story that doesn’t
have some restriction or downside to its powers.
And the last disclaimer is that this video
is not JUST about strong fighting fruits,
but also includes ones that are stupidly useful
in other ways.
And the perfect example of this is the Boturo
Boturo no mi, submitted by Martin, which has
my favorite devil fruit design in this entire
ranking.
I mean just look at this incredibly creative
ship in the bottle theme!
Now, what does this fruit do?
Well, it gives you the ability to shrink anything
and keep it inside a bottle.
Which doesn’t sound all that special, but
let me explain.
Imagine you are stuck at the Red Line, but
don’t want to go underwater to fishman island?
Well, with this fruit you can just put your
ship in a bottle and carry it over the Red
Line in your pocket.
Or imagine that you want to do a sneak attack
on Marineford.
With this fruit you can literally keep an
entire army in a bottle, and when you are
ready to fight, smashing the bottle will release
the entire army.
Which is simply incredible for sneaking around
and transporting anything, but it also has
some OP combat abilities as well.
For example, you trap fire or lightning in
a bottle and then release it to defeat an
opponent.
So yeah, truly a creative, overpowered, and
incredibly useful fruit.
Plus again, that design *Chef’s kiss.* Well
done, Martin.
However, even that insane ability is not as
useful as the Senti-Senti no mi, which was
submitted by Musa from India.
Now this power is absurdly broken, and if
used by the right person, could completely
tear down the entire World Government.
That’s because the ability of the Senti-Senti
no mi lets you learn everything about a person
or object by simply touching it.
And when I say everything, I mean EVERYTHING.
Now, to perfectly demonstrate how broken this
fruit is, let’s say you ate this fruit and
then touched a poneglyph.
Well you would now know what it says, who
made it, when and where it was made, and possibly
even where the others like it were placed
around the world.
Or if you touched a world noble, then you
would learn ALL THEIR SECRETS, including information
that the world government would never want
you to know.
So yeah, if that isn’t an insanely OP power
in a pirate-treasure hunt story, then I don’t
know what is.
But that’s not all because in combat you
could use this fruit to learn all of your
opponent's weaknesses and come up with the
best way to beat them.
However, even the incredible knowledge you’d
gain from the Senti fruit doesn’t compare
to the god-tier abilities of this next fruit.
That’s because with the powers of Zac-the-soda’s
Snail Snail - Model Den Den Mushi, you can
instantly communicate with people all over
the world.
Which, you might be saying, “well normal
den den mushis can already do that”, but
this power lets you communicate with literally
anyone without ever needing the snail phone.
Which let's be honest, how many times during
battle are you going to pause to pick up the
phone?
And this fruit truly shines with the ability
to have group calls inside of your head that
would let you instantly coordinate with your
entire squad to strategize during an all out
massive war.
I mean just imagine how useful this power
would have been when the straw hats were lost
in the forest during Skypiea, or during the
chaotic battle of Onigashima where there were
literally people fighting all over the castle.
In fact, this power would be perfect for a
strategist like Sanji, who could organize
everyone to fight in the best possible locations.
Which again isn’t a super broken combat
fruit on its own, but in a world as big as
one piece, instant communication would be
one of the most important abilities
This next fruit though is 100% a fruit that
I guarantee you’ve never heard of.
That’s because Hikiko from Italy submitted
one of my personal favorites in the ranking,
the Game Game no mi.
And now, we had many reality bending submissions,
but this one is SO INTERESTING that I just
had to include it on the list.
Basically, this fruit allows you to turn yourself
into a video game character and treat the
world like your own personal RPG adventure
game.
That means you can pause everyone during battle
to give yourself time to think, you can keep
a hidden inventory of up to 999 items, and
you can even save your progress up to three
times and return to that save point.
I mean come on, who wouldn’t want this fruit???
And just imagine you are about to get absolutely
crushed by Kaido, well you can quickly quit
out and restart the boss fight.
Simple as that.
And of course, what is a video game without
an incredible powerup system, so every time
you defeat an enemy you gain stat points to
level up your strength, speed, health, and
other abilities.
Plus you get item drops and money for every
enemy you defeat.
Although with any ridiculous power like this
there have to be some limitations, so you
can’t just restart as many times as you
like.
There has to be a limit, like a certain number
of times per day, and every time you restart
you lose any exp and loot you might have gained
since your last “save”.
Also, pausing during battle dramatically drains
your stamina, so it’s not like an infinite
time-stopping power.
Speaking of time fruits though, dozens of
submissions had time-based powers, but South
Africa’s Hasan submitted the Chrono-Chrono
no mi, which had the best combination of super
awesome time powers with reasonable limitations.
That’s because this fruit gives the user
the ability to create time bubbles around
themselves.
And within these bubbles they can freely speed
up or slow down time.
Which is absolutely devastating if you are
fighting someone one on one, because while
you both would be moving at the same speed
inside the bubble, you could easily confuse
them by changing the rate of speed at any
given time.
And of course time would be flowing normally
outside the bubble, but if you are moving
super fast inside of it, then you could quickly
dash around a battlefield to avoid attacks
or simply get to the other side.
In particular, this fruit would be perfect
in a situation like the Bird Cage from Dressrosa,
where you could make a bubble around yourself
and Doflamingo to effectively speed up the
fight against the former Warlord before the
string cage did any more damage to the city.
Awakening this fruit could also allow you
to create bigger time bubbles, but this power
can also leave you pretty exhausted, so you’d
still need to be pretty strong to use it.
Which is the exact opposite of this next fruit,
which might have the highest power ceiling
but also the lowest floor of any fruit on
this ranking.
This is the Share-Share fruit, which was submitted
by Kudi from Japan.
And this one is a bit complex, so make sure
you’re paying attention.
Now the base ability of the Share fruit allows
you to essentially share your physical abilities
with another person.
So you get weak, they get strong.
The catch is that once that person dies, you
get BOTH power back as well as ALL THE STRENGTH
of the person you shared your power with.
So if you are both just normal people, once
the person dies you’d get double the power
back.
But let’s say you gave your power to someone
super strong, then once THEY DIED you’d
get all that strength back in return.
So really over your entire life, your power
could grow an insane amount depending on how
many times you share and get back your powers.
Honestly, I’d love for a power like this
to even have an extra special ability where
the power of each user is transferred to the
next person who eats the fruit.
So kinda like the One for All power from My
Hero Academia.
Which means you won’t get much power if
you’re the first person to eat the fruit,
but just imagine if you are the tenth person
to eat it, then well you basically have godly
strength from the moment you eat the fruit.
Now it might be crazy to say, but this next
power could make you an even deadlier weapon
than any fruit that we’ve discussed so far.
That’s because notRowan submitted the Dew
Dew fruit, and oh man, do I love the concept
of this fruit.
Let me explain.
By touching an opponent, you can drain their
normal abilities such as speed, strength,
and endurance and turn them into large drops
of liquid.
You can take these Dew drops of power and
give those abilities to yourself, an ally,
or even an inanimate object.
So for example, if you were fighting Luffy,
you could drain some of his insane stamina
and absorb that stamina yourself.
And an awakened form of this power could even
let you take powers from inanimate objects
like fire, and then give those powers to another
person.
Plus there aren’t that many downsides to
this fruit, but one that makes sense is that
you don’t just gain your opponent’s power
forever.
Once you use up the amount you drained, then
it is gone.
Strong haki users could also resist the fruit,
which I guess is the case for most devil fruits,
but only if they have stronger haki than you.
If you thought that power might be incredibly
versatile, then just wait until you hear about
the Zodiac devil fruit submitted by FalconFig
of the United States of America.
And with this being the only zoan in the top
fifteen you can bet it is insanely creative.
The original idea is that the fruit would
grant you the power of one of the zodiac animals,
but honestly I think making this a mythical
zoan fruit could mean that you can freely
transform into any of the zodiac animals.
And while some of these look pretty harmless,
just think about the incredible diversity
of powers.
You can easily sneak around as a small rat
or you can blast your way through an entire
army as a massive dragon.
I can just imagine the rabbit having super
speed and something like the Ox being just
an insanely durable tank.
And since this is the zodiac we are talking
about, you might even get an extra power boost
depending on if the time of the year lines
up with the animal you are using.
So yeah, quite an awesome power to use in
basically any situation.
However, nothing is as powerful as Derek’s
devil fruit idea, the Sub Sub no mi, which
instantly lets you subscribe to the channel
for more one piece content just like this.
Plus there is an infinite amount of these
fruits, so go ahead… eat the fruit.
This next fruit though is almost too deadly
to even put into the story.
Because Ludwig from the Czech Republic submitted
the Kinoko Kinoko no mi, which is a logia
ability that turns you into mushroom spores.
Yes, I said that, MUSHROOM SPORES!
And if you know anything about mushrooms,
well then you should know this power can be
absolutely lethal.
Because as a mushroom spore person, you can
turn your body into literally billions of
tiny mushroom particles that could spread
in the air.
And if someone breathes in these spores, then
well it’s basically game over because mushrooms
have a ton of insane effects.
Some are so poisonous they can instantly kill
you, others can make you hallucinate, or even
make a person fall asleep.
Which means that you are untouchable from
close range because anyone who hits you would
be exposed to these tiny spores.
To take this one step further, awakening this
fruit could let you turn your entire environment
into mushroom spores as well, which means
a whole battlefield could instantly be a poisonous
minefield for anyone who gets too close.
So yeah, definitely an OP ability, and one
I would love to see in the story.
While this next fruit might not be as obviously
powerful, it is simply one of my favorite
abilities in all of anime, but has never shown
up in One Piece.
This is the Dice Dice fruit, which yes I know
Mr. 1’s fruit has the same name, but this
version submitted by River from Canada involves
actual black and white dice.
And wow!
Let me explain how this absurd power works.
First, the user can summon a six-sided die
which has the numbers 1-6 on the sides.
Then they throw it out and whatever number
it lands on, that effect is instantly used.
Now, what are those effects?
Well, I’m glad you asked because River supplied
a perfectly balanced list of awesome abilities.
Rolling a 1 lets you blast the dice at your
opponent like a bullet.
Rolling a 2 causes a flying wicked slash like
a curved scythe that can hit multiple opponents.
A three causes damage to an opponent and any
one else within six feet, kinda like a small
explosion.
A four causes a raining dance of blade-like
dice to rain down on the battlefield.
The five instantly lowers an opponent’s
speed and stamina.
And then a six makes a floating dart that
hovers around the user to attack anyone who
gets near you.
Which is all just amazingly cool if you ask
me, but of course the downside is that you
can’t exactly choose what power is used
at any given moment.
There might also be a short cooldown time
before you can do your next roll, So if you
really need to roll a four and rain down blades
on a bunch of opponents, you might not get
it right away.
Now, for this next fruit I want you to think
about the thing you want most in the world
right now.
Is it a huge stack of money?
A passing grade on your next exam?
A delicious sushi roll?
Yes please for me.
Well, with the Hoko Hoko no mi submitted by
Eli from the USA, you can create a magical
compass that will lead you right to whatever
you desire most.
Just like Jack Sparrow’s compass from the
Pirates of the Caribbean.
So yeah, finding the One Piece?
No problem, like at all, with this fruit.
Just follow the direction the compass is pulling
you towards and you will find it eventually.
It could also help you find other overpowered
devil fruits to sell or give to your friends,
and it even has applications in battle, such
as guiding you to find the best path to winning.
You can even create a compass on another person,
which will guide them to what they most desire.
But now, I know a bunch of you have been waiting
for this next ability because it was THE MOST
submitted devil fruit after the Water Fruit,
and that is of course the Blood Fruit.
Which again, there were a ton of these ideas
submitted and I thank you for all of them,
but the option I chose was submitted by Tarush
Pathak from India because it had the best
description of powers along with realistic
limitations.
And like the name says, this fruit allows
you to produce and control blood.
That means that you can whip out deadly blood
slashes for long range attacks.
You can make a blood sword to fight in close
combat.
And, yes, you can even control the blood INSIDE
of another person.
Which kinda creeps me out, but I guess it’s
something you all seem to enjoy.
But of course there have to be limits on this
simply broken ability, so for this fruit we’ll
say that you can’t make anyone kill themselves
by stopping their blood.
That would just be way too evil, but you can
slow down or speed up someone’s blood to
a certain extent to make them slower or to
help them heal faster.
You could also physically control their movements,
so you can be an evil puppet master.
Of course, controlling another person can
be overcome if the other person is strong
enough, so even this isn’t guaranteed to
win
you a fight, but it is still incredibly powerful.
Let me tell you though, if I was a devil fruit
user, I would not want to fight this next
fruit.
Because at number three we have the Leech
Leech fruit submitted by Vater.
And its powers are just like it sounds.
It lets you slowly drain other people’s
powers.
Which is similar to the Dew fruit we discussed
earlier, except THIS ONE drains devil fruit
abilities, not just strength and speed.
That means it is the perfect power for a long,
drawn out fight against a devil fruit user
because if you can survive long enough, your
opponent will eventually get weaker and weaker
just by being around you.
A perfect example is a marathon fight against
Kaido, which if you had this fruit and could
survive for a long time, you might stand a
chance at taking down one of these powerhouses.
To take it one step further, a possible awakening
for this fruit could also drain your opponent's
normal strength as well, which means that
in a long fight you are almost guaranteed
to win.
Though even the Leech fruit is not as overpowered
as this next fruit, which I’m honestly kind
of shocked it does not already exist in the
story.
That’s because Sahaj Shresth from Nepal
submitted the Yume Yume no mi, also called
the Dream Dream fruit.
And this fruit is mind-blowingly useful in
SO MANY situations.
The first power of this fruit allows you to
put someone to sleep by touching them, which
is just already ridiculously useful in a fight.
But that’s just the start because once your
target is asleep, you can then manipulate
their dream in the following ways.
You could change the dream however you want,
which could be either incredibly enjoyable
or absolutely terrifying.
You can also physically attack your target
in the dream world, which wouldn’t damage
their actual body because that’s just too
absurdly broken, but enough damage and you
could break their mind.
This power also lets you communicate through
dreams, so you can talk to an ally as long
as they are asleep.
And to top it off, awakening this fruit could
also let the user manifest their dream creations
into the real world.
Which, yeah, if you’ve ever had any wild
and crazy dreams like I have, then you should
know just how insane this ability actually
is.
Which brings us to the number one best devil
fruit that would break the world of One Piece,
which is the Play Play fruit submitted by
Joe.
And at first, I thought this would be just
like the Game fruit we discussed earlier,
but wow was I wrong.
Just listen to this.
The basic power of this fruit allows you to
make any sort of game into a binding contest
in the real world.
For example, if you are in a fight against
a super strong opponent, you can use this
fruit to turn the fight into a game that decides
the outcome.
And to truly understand how broken this is,
well let’s just imagine you or I ate this
fruit and strolled up to Blackbeard.
Well, of course there is no way we would ever
beat the Emperor in a fight, but using the
fruit we could make it so that he has to play
a life and death game of Rock, Paper, Scissors,
where the loser is literally killed.
Sure it might be a 50-50 chance, but it’s
infinitely better than having no chance at
all.
Another perfect example is let’s say bounty
hunter Zoro came to collect the bounty on
your head.
Well, instead of fighting you simply challenge
him to a race through a maze and you will
100% beat the always lost swordsman.
So yeah, a truly broken ability, because with
its powers, even a normal person has a chance
to defeat the strongest characters in the
world.
But if you truly want a cheat code to become
super powerful in One Piece, then there is
nothing better you can do than eat one of
the Top Five actual devil fruits in One Piece,
and if you want to see exactly what those
broken devil fruits are, you can click this
video right here.
And again a huge shout out to everyone all
over the world who submitted.
It was truly a blessing to see the huge variety
of countries represented in this community
and I’m super excited to do this again soon.
in fact, if you want to see 15 more fruits
from the almost 2000 submitted ones, let me
know in the comments For now, Shanks for watching,
and I’ll see you in the next one.